Hey so I woke up kind of 10 times worse
and it hurts so bad to swallow ariana
grande giving fans a health update and a
heads up about her sweetener tour not
really sure what's going on but I
unfortunately don't think I'll be able
to push through tonight and I'm so sad
and sorry the 26 year old singer who was
scheduled to perform in Lexington
Kentucky on Sunday night took to her IG
stories in the morning to let her fans
know that the show would not go on thank
you for understanding
and serving love I said as soon as I
know what's going on with my body but
thank you
friend stannie so sorry on saturday
ariana revealed that she's in so much
pain Philly fans that she's been sick
since her last London Show in
mid-october adding quote I don't know
how it's possible but my throat and head
are still in so much pain I sound ok I'm
just in a lot of pain and it's difficult
to breathe during the show I love being
on tour I love spending a lot of time
performing with my fans like for my fans
at that time the platinum-selling artist
informed fans that she was seeing her
doctor and doing her very best to get
better for Sunday's show writing that
the last thing I would ever want to do
was cancel a show at this point with so
few left but despite all the meds and IV
drips
and the excellent care from her mom and
friends an extremely apologetic Ariana
was forced to cancel her Sunday show I
feel like my fans are a very very very
important part of my life like in a very
real way they're like friends to me I
think that me being open with my fans
and my supporters it's like a very
important thing because like it's like
life you know what I mean so like
is beautiful
[Music]